now to the uk where prime minister boris
johnson is once again under pressure to
resign after the latest in a series of
scandals he just spoke to lawmakers in a
q a in parliament for the first time
since two of his cabinet ministers
stepped down yesterday roxanna siberia
is outside the prime minister's
residence at 10 downing street roxanna
good morning could someone else be
living there soon
good morning nate that is the big
question on many people's minds here
today and in the newspapers the subject
made at the front page of most of the
papers here this one reads last chance
saloon
but but frankly mr speaker the job of a
prime minister in difficult
circumstances boris is battling back
is to keep going
refusing to admit his time as britain's
prime minister is up despite two
dramatic resignations
the first blow came from his health
secretary sajid javid who said he could
no longer in good conscience continues
serving in this government
finance minister rishi sunak soon
followed declaring the public rightly
expect government to be conducted
properly competently and seriously the
resignations came just minutes after the
prime minister apologized for appointing
lawmaker christopher pincher to his
government despite knowing he faced
allegations of sexual misconduct in 2019
allegations pincher denies
in hindsight it was the wrong thing to
do i apologize to everybody who's been
badly affected
by it but as a sign that he's not
planning to step down anytime soon
johnson swiftly appointed replacements
for his departing ministers for some
here this morning it's too little too
late boris has got to go dead man
walking how's he survived this long but
the prime minister has survived a series
of recent scandals including partygate
when police fined him for breaking his
government's lockdown rules by attending
his own office birthday party that led
to a tense vote of no confidence by
members of his conservative party
johnson hung on by a thread
therefore i can announce that the
parliamentary party does have confidence
after last night's two resignations at
least 19 other members of johnson's
party also stepped down one of them said
there comes a time when you have to look
at your own personal integrity and that
time is now
really does seem like the pm is hanging
on by a thread roxanna thank you very
much